this is an orchestra rehearsal
and these young conductors can't
actually hear the music
for kids with hearing impairments
entering the world of classical music
can be a daunting experience
but this berlin-based orchestra is
breaking that barrier
they have been introducing classical
music to kids who are deaf or hard of
hearing
for the past eight years i'm christian
harvest and i play the violin in the
mala chamber orchestra
field music is a project we have with
hearing impaired children
we have been in hong kong we were in
rome we were
in london through classes and workshops
kids learn music on their own terms
using sensors other than
sound like touching the instruments as
they vibrate
and feeling the rhythm of the percussion
through the floor
or even by simply watching the musicians
play
some of them tell us why you make weird
faces when you play the violin
you enter the music so it can be painful
it can be really
really joyful it's very intensive
and the kids of course react much more
on that because that's their language
others totally moved and tell me that
it's the most beautiful thing they've
done
[Music]
[Applause]
at the end of the program the kids are
put in charge as the conductors for a
day
kids like mara who can only hear with
the assistance of a hearing aid
my name is
i feel very moved actually i start
crying
oh am really happy to see how
how moved these kids are by simple
things
with the music
[Applause]
[Music]
you